bonsoir et bienvenue dans savoure garde
notre grand témoin ce soir nous invite à
sortir du syndrome de la fourmi bonsoir
Flora gaybahi le syndrome de la fourmi
c'est le titre de votre livre aux
éditions de l'Observatoire vous êtes
essayé et entrepreneuse le syndrome de
la fourmi et bien c'est à paralysant
c'est barrière invisibles et mentales
qui nous empêchent de passer à l'action
on va en parler longuement dans cette
émission puisqu'elle va la placer sous
le signe du climat ce soir on va
commencer par débattre de l'ISF
climatique c'est un sacré pavé dans la
mare qui a jeté l'économiste Jean Pisani
ferry en début de semaine dans son
rapport remis à la première ministre il
préconise de taxer les plus riches pour
financer la transition écologique alors
le gouvernement ferme pour leur
complètement la porte mais il va bien
falloir trouver des milliards pour
parvenir à la neutralité carbone climat
qui doit payer la facture grand débat
dans un instant avec nos invités sur ce
plateau avant de retrouver 20h15 bien
sûr les parties pris de nos affranchis
et puis Bourbon Express l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée voilà pour le menu
vous savez tout vous me suivez Flora
Gaby ça vous regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
le coût de la transition ne sera accepté
que si l'effort est équitablement
répartis là-dessus tout le monde
s'accorde mais quand il s'agit de savoir
qui va payer et bien ça se complique
alors faut-il un ISF vert comme le
préconise le rapport de l'économiste
Jean pisaniferi bonsoir Mathieu Lefebvre
et merci d'être là vous êtes député
renaissance du Val-de-Marne hostile on
peut le dire à ce nouvel impôt sur les
plus riches vous nous direz pourquoi
vous débattez ce soir avec Manon Aubry
bonsoir heureux député la France
insoumise vous avez travaillé à Oxfam
qui propose depuis des années cette ISF
climatique et va SAS bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous député Europe Écologie
les vers de Paris votre partie qui
milite aussi depuis des années pour
cette impôts enfin bon soirée
ravi de vous retrouver sur ce plateau
vous êtes directrice de l'iFRAP ce
laboratoire d'idées libérale
osons le mot ou va notre argent c'est
votre dernier livre aux éditions de
l'obser soit cette question fiscale elle
est centrale dans ce livre Flora gaybahi
il est quasiment pour vous ce débat le
sujet vous passionne donc n'hésitez pas
à intervenir ou même interroger nos
invités quand vous le souhaitez la
parole pour commencer à Stéphane
blackovski un ISS écolo l'idée fait son
chemin vous allez le voir y compris un
tout petit peu dans la majorité le
chrono de Blacko c'est parti
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
à toutes et tous alors cette ISF vert
pour commencer le rapport qui fait
polémique donc je vous le montre au
moins la couverture ne serait-ce que la
synthèse elle fait 154 pages donc je
n'ai pas tout lu c'est pas si grave
parce qu'en fait il y a simplement cinq
lignes qui font polémique dans ce
rapport c'est un clic qui propose de
taxer les plus riches pour financer la
transition donc pour résumer ces cinq
lignes ce que dit le rapport c'est que
l'ensemble des Français en 4700
milliards d'actifs financiers de
classement mais 3000 de ces milliards
sont entre les mains de 10% des Français
les plus riches donc pour financer la
transition écologique on taxerait ses
10% de 5 milliards par an pas toujours
mais quand même pendant 30 ans ce qui
ferait 150 milliards au total pour
financer la transition écologique donc
l'idée n'est pas nouvelle souvenez-vous
de la présidentielle toute la gauche
était d'accord pour créer un ISF
climatique Mélenchon Hidalgo Jadot
chacun avait un peu sa manière de
calculer l'ISF mais ils étaient d'accord
c'est une idée que défend depuis
longtemps pas mal ONG notamment Oxfam
qui pointe souvent du doigt les plus
riches voyez ils avaient fait un rapport
où il disait que
63 milliards d'air français produisent
autant de CO2 que la moitié de la
population soit 34 millions de Français
donc c'est un petit peu tension
d'ailleurs Roxane la reconnaît parce
qu'en fait c'est bien sûr pas les 63
personnes qui produisent autant de CO2
mais les entreprises dans lesquelles ils
sont actionnaires donc ça revient à dire
qu'en fait il faudrait restreindre
l'activité économique si on veut moins
polluer donc n'empêche à gauche bah on
se réjouit évidemment du retour de l'ISF
dans le débat d'autant que vous l'avez
dit Jean Pisani ferry n'est pas un
gauchiste illuminé ni un écologiste
radical ce que se plaît à souligner donc
William Martinet qui lui est de elle et
les filles en écoute
pour les classes moyennes et populaires
la transition écologique le changement
des comportements ça ne pourra pas se
faire si on demande pas des efforts au
plus aisés et je suis en effet en accord
avec la proposition qui a été fait par
l'économiste Pisani ferry dont il faut
rappeler qu'en 2017 il était un des
soutiens d'Emmanuel Macron pendant sa
campagne bah oui bah alors si même celui
qui a rédigé le programme économique du
candidat Macron en 2017 nous dit que oui
l'ISF climatique c'est pas une mauvaise
idée il y a de quoi s'interroger
d'ailleurs même au gouvernement et on
s'est dit bah oui après tout ça ou
peut-être la peine d'ouvrir le débat en
tout cas c'est ce que disait Christophe
Béchu on écoute
c'est un sujet qui ne peut pas être
tabou tout le monde n'a pas le même
bilan carbone ou les mêmes émissions ou
les mêmes empreintes de la même manière
qu'à l'échelle mondiale il y a des
dispositifs de solidarité qui consiste à
demander au pays du nord de financer une
partie de la transition il est légitime
que cette question elle puisse se poser
dans la sphère nationale alors vous avez
entendu comme moi là on a vraiment
l'impression que le gouvernement est
prêt à ouvrir le débat bah en fait pas
du tout pas le problème c'est que les
cristaux Béchu il était pas au courant
des positions de Bruno Le Maire sur la
question la cependant c'est marqué dans
le journal regarde il l'a dit en 2020 il
l'a répété en 2021 il leur répété en
2022 il la répété en 2023 pas de hausse
dans un pot tant qu'il sera abercé en
fait quand il lit le rapport Bruno Le
Maire il est au moins d'accord sur une
chose c'est le chiffrage il dirait oui
70 milliards par an pour financer la
transition c'est un peu près ça mais il
propose d'autres sources de financement
par exemple l'épargne en écoute
vous avez aujourd'hui 530 milliards
d'euros qui sont sur le livret A sur le
livret de développement durable et qui
sont pas forcément fléchés vers les
investissements verts nous allons
obliger dans les plans d'assurance vie
chaque plan d'assurance vie avoir ce
qu'on appelle une unité de compte qui
doit servir au financement la transition
écologique aux investissements verts bon
j'ai un peu essayer de résumer pour
lancer le débat donc c'est parti donc
faut-il taxer les 10% des Français les
plus riches il y a 90% des Français ils
doivent pas être contre bon courage bon
courage à ceux qui défendent les 10% les
plus riches
limpide et plutôt marrant ce soir
attonné
même participer et même c'est
l'architecte du programme économique
d'Emmanuel Macron en 2017 c'est un
économiste mesurée par rapport à ce défi
c'est le défi du siècle le réchauffement
climatique c'est pas le moment d'ouvrir
la porte à la fiscalité sur les plus
aisées en tout cas je pense qu'il pose
une vraie question Jean Pisany ferry
mais moi je suis convaincu que c'est pas
avec un impôts en plus qu'on aura des
degrés en moins sur la planète et
surtout ce qui m'inquiète c'est que
c'est pas pour les 10% les plus riches
on a vu comment ça se passait par le
passé on commence par agnèsf et on finit
par une taxe carbone qui va finir par
peser sur tous les Français c'est
toujours le mot exceptionnel sur le
patrimoine financier des 10% des
Français les plus aisés sachant que
Stéphane l'a bien rappelé 66 milliards
par an d'ici à 2030 et tout ça a été
chiffré par France stratégie de façon
extrêmement équilibrée budget par budget
c'est des briques qui ont été montés
pour arriver à ces chiffres là qu'est-ce
que vous dites toujours le risque que
l'on a quand on fait le choix
d'augmenter les impôts on commence par
les plus riches et on finit par les
augmenter sur tous les Français
nous avons supprimé l'ISF on a eu le
courage de supprimer l'ISF on va pas
aujourd'hui faire et défaire pourquoi
parce que cette politique elle a eu des
résultats on est aujourd'hui le pays qui
est le plus attractif pour les capitaux
étrangers on recrée de l'emploi
industriel dans notre pays et ça on le
doit aux décisions d'investissement qui
était lié à une politique fiscale
totalement obsolète en 2017 donc il est
tabou ce sujet là il est pas tabou en
revanche je crois que recréer un impôt
encore une fois ne fait pas baisser les
degrés sur la planète je pense qu'il y a
des solutions qui sont très utiles par
exemple quand on propose de réorienter
le bonus malus sur les véhicules quand
on propose d'augmenter le malus je crois
qu'on oriente sérieusement les
comportements mais personne ne fait le
lien et Monsieur Pisani Ferry sur lui
faire office ne fait se dire direct il a
calculé ce qu'il faut faire par exemple
supprimer je sais pas moi les choisir au
fioul ce que ça implique d'abord dans la
réalité et puis ensuite c'est chiffré
c'est financé et on essaye de trouver
les financements même Pascal Camphin
Manon Aubry qui préside le groupe écolo
au Parlement européen il est de votre
présence il préside la commission
environnement dans le groupe Renaissance
absolument dit que et bien cette
question de l'isfaire n'est pas tabou
vous vous méditez là-dessus depuis très
longtemps en même temps la politique
économique du gouvernement elle a plutôt
posée ses fruits quand on regarde la
tractivité quand on regarde le retour
des investisseurs c'est vrai la fin du
chômage ou quasi c'est vrai qu'elle a
porté ses fruits en termes de cadeaux
fait au plus riches de ce point de vue
là l'objectif est atteint c'est vrai
c'est des milliards d'euros qui ont été
reversés chaque année au plus riche
quand vous dites monsieur que quand on
commence par les riches on finit par les
pauvres mais pardonnez-moi vous avez
commencé par taxer les plus pauvres et
vous n'avez jamais fini par les plus
riches par exemple la taxe carbone dont
vous parlez qui a provoqué la
mobilisation des gilets jaunes Emmanuel
Macron est revenu dessus au niveau
français elle vient d'être votée au
niveau européen sous l'arme pulsion de
vos députés Renaissance donc la taxation
des plus pauvres elle est déjà en place
taxer les plus pauvres concrètement ces
textes carbone c'est une taxe sur le
logement et sur le transport donc c'est
quand vous allez prendre votre voiture
et quand vous avez chauffé votre
logement la trajectoire d'augmentation a
été à la revue depuis la crise des
gilets jaunes par le président
la trajectoire prise par le Président de
la République c'est très clairement de
faire des cadeaux au plus riche et de
mettre la charge fiscale sur les plus
pauvres donc la question qui est posée
aujourd'hui elle est double elle est
d'une part comment on finance parce que
ce que propose Jean pisaniphery c'est ça
rapporte que 5 milliards d'euros par an
à l'heure où il en faut plus de 60 et la
deuxième chose
ça fait quand même 150 milliards donc
c'est pas rien c'est pas rien 35 pardon
c'est par exemple et j'y suis en faveur
mais vous voyez dès qu'on commence un
petit peu par ça déjà y compris du côté
de renaissance il crie déjà il pousse
déjà des cris d'orfray donc on voit à
quel point on est loin d'atteindre les
besoins de financement que nous avons et
puis pourquoi un ISF vert est aussi
nécessaire parce que en réalité et ça a
été très bien présenté en amorce les
plus riches sont aussi ce qui ont les
comportements les plus climatissibles
les plus nocives pour le climat si même
vous enlevez la part des investissements
et ne serait-ce que sur leur
consommation le fait de prendre des
yachts des jets privés etc les 10% les
plus aisés ils émettent 5 fois plus de
carbone que la moitié la plus pauvre il
est normal qu'on leur demande de
contribuer davantage que les plus
peuvent voilà pourquoi un ISF vers est
nécessaire et j'ai envie de dire c'est
une des nombreuses briques à poser pour
repérer je vais aller voir Agnès
mais je pense que vous êtes assez en
phase avec votre camarade insoumise à
vos côtés
expliquez-nous véritablement cette cette
politique de pose fiscale en tout cas il
y a il y a pas eu de hausse d'impôts
elle a elle a porté ses fruits en termes
d'attractivité la constance c'est la
confiance répète le président de la
République tout ça c'est grâce à
l'absence d'impôt en plus d’abord
rappeler un chiffre en 2022 on n'a
jamais eu un taux de prélèvement
obligatoire en France aussi élevé depuis
les années 90 c'est pas moi qui le dis
c'est les documents annexés à la loi de
finances pour 2023 on arrive maintenant
à 43
45,3% pardon de taux de prélèvements
obligatoires par rapport au PIB on n'a
jamais payé autant d'impôts
proportionnellement par rapport à la
richesse nationale et ça c'est quand
même très important de le dire il y a
pas eu de baisse massives d'impôts après
quand on regarde la sexualité
quand on regarde le pot quand on regarde
la fiscalité du capital puisque
aujourd'hui on parle d'un ISF climatique
ça veut dire taxer le capital on l'a
bien dit des 3000 milliards finalement
de placements financiers ou d'assurance
vie etc et le patrimoine financier des
10%
le capital
France stratégie a fait un rapport qui a
été publié en octobre 2022 sur ce sujet
qui est passionnant j'incite tout le
monde à aller le lire sur Internet et ce
rapport il montre quoi que par rapport à
la richesse nationale depuis 2017 il n'y
a pas eu de baisse de pourcentage de
fiscalité sur le capital en France on
est toujours à 10,7%. 10,7%, c'est 2,5
points de plus que la moyenne de la zone
euro dans laquelle nous sommes tous les
entreprises de les ont vu quand même
leur fiscalité baissée on pourra y
revenir la société on pourra y revenir
moi l'écart que je vois avec la zone
euro depuis 2017 il a pas baissé en
milliards
laissez-moi finir allez-y moi finir
quand on regarde la fiscalité des
ménages puisque là c'est sont les
ménages tout à fait intéressent sur le
capital on a toujours dans ce rapport de
France stratégie on est à 1,6 points de
PIB pour les ménages français en
imposition du capital alors que la
moyenne de l'UE c'est numéro 7 points de
PIB ça veut dire qu'on est à 22
milliards de plus donc si on voulait se
mettre à la moyenne des pays européens
on serait pas à la hausse on serait à la
baisse donc pour vous si on augmente les
impôts des plus riches ils fuient
directement à l'étranger est-ce que le
fait de taxer plus de capital ça nous a
enrichi en France non on est en train de
perdre des places par rapport aux autres
pays dans les années 80 on était en 11e
en richesse par habitant maintenant on
est 25e François l'argument vous allez
nous dire
est-ce que les autres pays ont gardé
leur vie le Danemark l'Autriche plein de
pays européens ont renoncé à l'ISF
depuis les années 90 pourquoi parce
qu'ils ont vu que cette fiscalité
finalement elle était néfaste pour
l'économie de leur pays ils ont eu
raison donc dire qu'on va faire ça alors
que on taxe déjà beaucoup plus que les
autres et alors que la plupart de nos
voisins européens ont arrêté ce genre de
fiscalité c'est vraiment aller on entend
toujours cet argument la France et la
champion nationale bien compris
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ça moi
j'ai d'abord l'impression que Madame
verdier-molinier s'intéresse pas
beaucoup au climat parce que nous on
avait peut-être pas prononcé le mot une
seule fois là ce qui nous occupe c'est
comment on finance la transition
climatique ce que nous dit le rapport
c'est très important c'est que d'abord
qu'il faut doubler l'effort de réduction
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
donc il fallait beaucoup plus vite il
faut 25 à 34 milliards d'investissement
public et j'insiste là dessus c'est à
dire qu'il faut mettre des moyens
budgétaires donc ça veut dire que s'il y
a des dépenses il va falloir les
financer et comment on finance il y a
trois leviers c'est soit l'endettement
soit la réduction des niches fiscales
des faces au climat on va y revenir
parce que là je pense qu'il y a une
source importante et là aussi le
gouvernement n'avance pas sur ce sujet
et la troisième possibilité c'est la
fiscalité minimale
la fiscalité
sur des dépenses donc pour vous il faut
pas investir il faut pas investir être
humain c'est ça que vous nous dites qui
sont nuisibles à l'environnement madame
abris vous avez maintenant
vous avez donc vous n'êtes pas pour la
on est carburants des engins de travaux
publics à hauteur de 300 millions
d'euros est-ce que vous pouvez
m'expliquer pourquoi pourquoi vous
refusez de supprimer cette niche fiscale
parce que c'est compliqué les débats de
fiscalité
Flora gabbali je vais vous montrer une
image vous allez réagir mais aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs vous en revenez vous étiez
devant le siège de Total Manon Aubry
soutient l'assemblée générale des
actionnaires de Total où vous le voyez
des jeunes militants ou qu'on qualifie
activistes du climat ont essayé de
manifester vous le voyez aussi les
forces de l'ordre était présente il y a
eu déjà de gaz lacrymogènes et puis et
puis c'est mis les temps qui manifestait
pacifiquement essayé de bloquer l'entrée
des actionnaires on est dans un moment
spécial on est dans un moment après la
crise des retraites cette question de la
justice sociale mais aussi fiscale elle
est elle est centrale alors là il s'agit
des super profits au total mais c'est un
peu lié le sujet de la justice fiscale
pour les entreprises les particuliers
c'est quand même c'est quand même lié
cette ISF climatique pour vous c'est
nécessaire bah pour moi ce débat il
arrive en ce moment c'est pas du tout
par hasard c'est à dire que ça dépend en
fonction ce que j'ai entendu là d'où on
se place si on se place du point de vue
des caisses de l'État et de comment les
renflouer puisque Jean Pisani Ferri a
demandé 66 milliards de plus par an pour
financer la transition à 3000 milliards
de dettes alors ça paraît assez juste
que les 10% les plus riches prennent
plus à leur charge ce financement que
les 90% de la population restant on a vu
qu'il y a sfvr ça peut apporter selon
les calculs et les propositions entre 5
et 15 milliards par an le chiffre de 15
milliards c'est précisément le chiffre
qu'on a entendu pendant toute la réforme
des retraites puisque la réforme des
retraites a aussi vocation à apporter 15
milliards par an dans les caisses ça
relativise aussi donc si on se
positionne d'un point de vue de comment
pouvoir redistribuer et mener la
transition écologique alors évidemment
ça a du sens maintenant si on fait un
pas de côté et que on se positionne
comment on conduit la transition
écologique et comment on la conduit de
la manière la plus efficace on le voit
bien et c'est exactement l'objet de mon
livre dont on va parler le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que à chaque fois
qu'on fait un pas en avant on fait trois
pas en arrière puisque on est en Pétré
dans un modèle économique politique
démocratique qui fait que on n'arrive
pas à conduire une vraie transition
écologique tous les chiffres Le Mans le
montre et aujourd'hui l'urgence fait que
on peut plus permettre de faire ce genre
de pas en avant trois pas en arrière et
permettez-moi de vous dire que ce
rapport sort il a été publié par France
stratégie qui est une agence de conseil
gouvernemental et ça permet souvent un
peu de créer du débat politique de créer
un sujet dans l'opinion et pour moi ça
arrive pas du tout par hasard
aujourd'hui parce que on se souvient
dans le premier quinquennat le débat de
la taxe carbone avait créé les gilets
jaunes et avait quand même permis de
mettre les Français les uns contre les
autres présenter comme une taxe anti
gilet jaune et à ce moment là pour moi
le gouvernement a fait une faute
politique et symbolique qui est
extrêmement grave qui est qu'ils ont
opposé ils ont créé l'opposition fictive
entre fin du monde et fin du mois et
cette et moi en tant que activité
écologique sur écologie sur le terrain
vous vous imaginez pas le nombre de
discussions qu'on doit avoir pour
réparer cette faute grave qui a été
faite par le gouvernement et j'ai peur
que avec cette histoire d'isfaire le
gouvernement relance une certaine
manière un moyen de cliver les Français
des uns contre les autres d'opposer les
riches et les pauvres juste après en
plus le débat sur les retraites où on a
déjà vu je croyais ça
je crois qu'en fait elle est récupérée 5
milliards ici 10 milliards ici 15
milliards ici c'est évidemment important
mais en fait la transition écologique
c'est un modèle de civilisation
différent donc si on regarde le truc par
par des petites portes ici et là on
n'arrivera pas à conduire les vrais
changements alors la question c'est
quand même où sont les leviers on a bien
compris que vous ne vouliez pas
augmenter les impôts y compris des plus
riches reste la dette il y a de la bonne
dette à lire le rapport de Jean Pisani
ferry vous nous direz ce que vous en
pensez mais c'est noir sur blanc et
écrit il me veut même enlever les
investissements vers du calcul des 3%
sur les déficits quels sont les autres
options possibles on voit cela avec
Hélène Bonduelle et on revient en débat
juste après
nous ne sommes pas durablement condamnés
à choisir entre croissance et climat ce
sont les premières phrases du rapport et
pourtant le coût de la transition
écologique est considérable et il pèsera
inévitablement sur l'économie sur les
dépenses publiques tout le monde va
devoir payer un peu mais si vous voulez
de la part de la grande question c'est
la part publique et la part privée c'est
à peu près moitié-moitié sur nos
évaluations
rénover les logements le tertiaire
s'équiper en véhicule électrique un
investissement supplémentaire évalué à
66 milliards d'euros par an re déployer
les financements des énergies brunes
vers les énergies vertes et l'une des
pistes on a 10 milliards d'euros de
dépenses budgétaires et fiscales brunes
anti-écologiques exactement mais à un
moment donné si notre économie se
transforme c'est normal aussi que ces
dépenses de soutien à un des énergies
fossiles se transforme mais cela ne
suffir pas la France va devoir
s'endetter selon les auteurs au risque
d'alourdir l'endettement de l'état de
près de 25 points de PIB en 2040 au
moment où le président de la République
tente de rassurer les marchés et les
agences de notation l'équation n'est pas
si simple je pense que les agences de
notation ne sont pas idiotes et si on
leur explique pourquoi on s'endette et
si on leur explique que c'est
endettement il est générateur de revenus
futurs elles peuvent le comprendre reste
les impôts c'est la troisième voie
préconisée par le rapport une ligne
rouge pour le gouvernement Emmanuel
Macron entend même les baissés pour les
classes moyennes je préfère une
francionne des emplois ce qui est le cas
aujourd'hui et ce qui est aussi le
résultat d'une politique de baisse des
impôts en particulier sur les
entreprises qu'une France qui sera
championne des impôts les auteurs du
rapport ne cessons donc pas trompés en
écrivant que nous entrons dans les
décennies de toutes les difficultés
d'autant que pour être accepté la
transition écologique devra s'appuyer
sur des efforts partagés
bon alors si on n'arrive pas à vous
mettre d'accord sur l'ISS climatique
vous saurez d'accord sur la dette de
toute façon il va falloir s'endetter
quand on voit les montants colossaux des
investissements à faire c'est ce que
dis-je en pylaniferi très clairement
dans son rapport Matthieu lefebvrement
de la transition écologique c'est une
évidence mais ce qu'on oublie de dire
nos contradictrices c'est que il y a
d'autres moyens pour se dégager des
marges de manœuvre on peut réduire les
dépenses qui sont en néfastes à
l'environnement on peut réduire les
dépenses fiscales qui sont néfastes
bien entendu
des exemples
sur les billets d'avion pourquoi est-ce
qu'il y a une TVA réduite sur les
billets d'avion c'est totalement
contraire aux objectifs
national et on peut faire que dans le
cadre à chaque fois vous avez une
réponse et donc quels sont les niches
fiscales que vous nous avons fait plein
de propositions quels sont les niches
fiscales néfastes au climat que vous
avez réduites
1er janvier 2025
mais simplement on est dans un pays qui
a quand même une passion pour la
fiscalité dès qu'il y a un problème on
vous pose une question très concrète sur
les niches fiscales c'est le levier que
vous privilégiez lesquels vous supprimez
également publiques s'il s'agit vraiment
de faire une réforme de l'État d'ampleur
qu'est-ce que vous faites on a tout un
tas de soutien des entreprises à des
dépenses brunes par exemple dans des
domaines qui sont en effet pour pour la
pollution mais c'est pas c'est pas tant
le sujet aujourd'hui le sujet
aujourd'hui
c'est est-ce qu'il faut un impôt en plus
moi ma réponse c'est faut-il
poser une question sous-jacente sur
laquelle il y a pas de conclusion en
gros il dit c'est bien de s'endetter
pour investir d'accord en l'occurrence
c'est pour la transition climatique mais
globalement on est tous d'accord que on
doit s'endetter pour investir et pas
pour fonctionner ce gros problème que
nous avons en France c'est que depuis
les années 90 on s'est beaucoup plus
massivement endetté pour fonctionner que
pour investir pourquoi parce qu'on s'est
endetté pour payer le chômage pour payer
les retraits pour payer
de l'ifrappe vous êtes d'accord pour
s'endetter pour investir pour cette
transition climatique si c'est fléchés
le sujet le sujet c'est de remplacer de
la dette de fonctionnement par de la
dette d'investissement et de pas
s'endetter plus quand il y a pas de
dogme quand monsieur Pisani ferry dit
dans son rapport en 2040 il faudrait
qu'on ait 25% de dette en plus c'est pas
du tout ça qu'il faut faire il faut dire
quels sont les dépenses qui nous
emmènent en fonctionnement vers de la
dette supplémentaire et on arrête on
devrait pas s'endetter d'ailleurs dans
les pays du nord de l'Europe ils sont
dettent pas pour financer finalement les
dépenses de sécurité sociale les
dépenses de protection sociale
rien à voir le problème c'est que quand
vous posez la question quelle dépense il
faut baisser vous dites il faut des ex
le concret mais moi je vous en donne des
exemples concrets si on dit l'assurance
chômage doit être équilibrée et ben on
se débrouille avec le budget qu'on a si
on dit la science maladie doit être
équilibrée c'est pareil si on dit les
retraites doivent être équilibrées et ça
rejoint ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure
bah oui et équilibrer les retraites ça
veut dire repousser l'âge ça veut dire
travailler plus longtemps
allez ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'on a d'énormes marges pour investir
plus et malheureusement au lieu de dire
qu'il y a une possibilité justement de
stopper cette dette de fonctionnement
qui existe pas ailleurs dans ces
proportions du tout et le rapport n'en
parle pas et tout ce qu'il dit c'est
finalement augmenter les impôts ou
niches fiscales mini fiscale ça veut
dire quoi si on en supprime ça veut dire
qu'on augmente aussi les impôts ça veut
dire qu'on augmente aussi les
prélèvements obligatoires et finalement
les entreprises qui polluent justement
elles ont besoin de pouvoir investir
pour changer leur modèle est-ce que dit
total aujourd'hui
verte le crédit un peu réinvesti le
crédit impôt recherche
de changer de modèle et de les critiquer
ceux qui ont bien pour rechercher pour
fonctionner peut-être que là on aura
d'énormes marges de manoeuvre au milieu
on parle de d'investissement non pas par
rapport à une date de fonctionnement
mais d'investissement moi ce que je vois
c'est qu'au fond déjà on pourrait se
réjouir que on est plus dans un débat
faut-il agir on est dans un débat de
financement donc ça veut dire que on est
sorti du déni on pourrait déjà se
féliciter de ça et qu'on avance on est
on est tous très clairement conscient de
ce défi et de cette urgence mais quand
on regarde le financement c'est
l'impasse là ce soir et quand on pendant
qu'on parle sur les voies de financement
j'entends que ce que propose les
macronistes à l'heure actuelle c'est de
couper dans les dépenses et donc de
couper dans la protection sociale couper
quoi demain dans nos hôpitaux ou nos
écoles c'est la seule voie de
financement que vous avez proposé c'est
de couper dans les dépenses et
aujourd'hui la réalité c'est que à la
fois du côté de l'endettement si vous
regardez les règles qui sont qui vont
revenir au galop au niveau européen
c'est le retour de la règle des 3% de
déficit et des 60% en deux dettes à
travers lesquelles il y aura pas
d'investissement et la deuxième
commission
de répondre quand même sur la mise à
contribution des plus riches quand tu as
dit Agnès Verdier dit que le taux moyen
d'un position en France est de 45 % elle
a raison mais ce qu'elle omet de dire
c'est que la France est devenue un
paradis fiscal pour les plus riches
parce que en pratique les 370 familles
les plus riches de notre pays ne payent
que 2% d'impôts alors ça il faut
fabriquer
beaucoup de temps sur ce plateau pour
vous exprimer et donc l'enjeu c'est
comment on met à contribution les
personnes les plus riches dont on a déjà
prouvé que leur comportement étaient les
plus polluants et si vous prenez même
les 37 familles les plus riches vous
êtes à 0, alors il faut peut-être
expliquer donc je veux juste terminer
là-dessus quand Bernard Arnault par
exemple si on lui prend juste 5% de sa
fortune il reste 200 milliards d'euros
qu'on m'explique comment Bernard Arnault
peut difficilement survivre avec 200
dégâts
on a donné la parole simplement il faut
il y a des téléspectateurs et on
s'adresse aussi à eux faire un peu de
pédagogie ça a quand même ça heurte
quand on entend que les 380
milliardaires français ne qu'est-ce que
je raconte pas du tout les 370 familles
en France c'est Gabriel zuckman c'est un
économiste qui a enseignant Berkley à
Londres et qui revient en France
explique que oui pour ces familles là et
bien
d'une certaine façon la France est un
paradis fiscal parce que ils ne sont
imposés sur leurs revenus qu'à hauteur
de 2% absolument ça quand même je suis
sûr que ce qui nous écoutent vont avoir
l'oreille qui se lève et vous allez
pouvoir réagir et bah ça puis Agnès
Verdier d'abord première chose tout à
l'heure vous disiez on est sorti du déni
sur les questions climatiques mais on
est sorti du déni pour entrer dans la
com aujourd'hui il n'y a aucun moyen
pour le climat aucun moyen suffisant et
c'est ce que montre une fois de plus ce
rapport puisque il faut 25 à 34
milliards supplémentaires donc on voit
bien qu'on n'est pas du tout à la
hauteur la deuxième chose que montre ce
rapport et ça rejoint les analyses de
cabriolkman c'est que ce sont les plus
riches qui contribuent le plus aux
dérèglement climatique et que au
contraire ce sont les plus pauvres qui
pâtissent le plus du dérèglement
climatique aujourd'hui les 10% les plus
aisés et bien elle emprunte carbone et
trois fois supérieur aux 10% les moins
les moins riches alors que quand vous
êtes pauvre vous ne pouvez pas vous
adapter quelqu'un qui est riche il va
pouvoir changer de voiture pour un
véhicule électrique il va pouvoir isoler
son logement éventuellement mettre la
clim même si je lui je lui conseille pas
il va pouvoir partir en vacances quand
il y a des canicules quand vous êtes
pauvre vous êtes condamné en fait à ne
pas pouvoir vous adapter et à rester
dans votre logement de la justice elle
est fondamentale elle est fondamentale
et d'ailleurs je trouve qu'au contraire
ça serait une mesure de cohésion sociale
parce que
qui est une solidarité de ceux qui
contribuent le plus aux dérèglement
climatique pour que ceux qui ont le
moins puissent s'adapter et par exemple
avoir une rénovation thermique de leur
logement aujourd'hui le reste à charge
c'est entre 12 et 20.000 euros pour une
prime modeste c'est impossible de
pouvoir
ces mots d'unités et et de cohésion vous
lirez sur la France paradis fiscal pour
les Ultra riches je trouve que là on est
complètement parti sur un débat qui est
totalement hors sol on a en France des
statistiques je vous renvoie ces travaux
mais on a des stators on a des
statistiques qui sont hyper clair par
exemple sur l'impôt sur le revenu les
10% qui déclarent le plus ils payent 75%
du montant total de l'impôt sur le
revenu c'est pas le seul alors arrêtez
on a fait on a fait le travail vous
m'avez laissé parler
on a fait le travail sur les 10% sur
l'ensemble des impôts directs il paye
50% de la note aujourd'hui donc c'est
eux qui financent le plus le modèle ce
sont eux ce sont de la TVA en France
le modèle français et il y a une
concentration d'impôts qui s'aggrave en
2019 c'était plutôt autour de 70% que
les 10% qui gagnent plus payer en impôt
sur le revenu maintenant c'est 75 il y a
deux points sur le revenu
il y a de moins en moins il de moins en
plus faire vos courses
de finalement de ménage qui paye l'impôt
sur le revenu en France et quand vous
regardez les autres pays il y a
proportionnellement beaucoup plus de
ménages qui sont assujettis il y a
beaucoup moins d'impôts qui pèsent sur
les diplôme
fiscalité sur les simplement une
question dans le rapport j'entiste any
ferry parle d'une révolution
industrielle majeure devant nous le
rapport c'est uniquement sur les
réductions d'émissions c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'atténuation mais il va y avoir
des dépenses liées à l'adaptation et ce
qui va être énorme si on est à 50 degrés
à Paris il va y avoir énormément de
choses qui vont coûter très cher pour
éviter le pire donc vous vous dites quoi
il y a de quoi quand même se réjouir de
ce défi là et vous nous donnez des
espoirs d'être à la hauteur
j'étais sur ce point d'accord voilà bah
rendez-vous dans l'hémicycle donc ça
tombe bien la grande loi de
programmation c'est on a quatre points
de PIB par rapport à l'ensemble de la
planète
on va attendre de toute façon de déficit
commercial donc on va attendre les
arbitrages du président de la République
au moins en France je crois pas que ce
soit la solution il faut produire plus
au contraire on verra qu'elle levier
voilà sera privilégié pour répondre à la
question donc de qui doit payer ou qui
va payer la facture merci on s'arrête là
merci d'être venu débattre sur LCP vous
restez avec moi Flora gaybahi dans une
dizaine de minutes les parties pris de
nos affranchis ce soir vous les voyez le
mot de la semaine de la sémiologue
Mariette d'arrêt grand des civilisations
c'est ce néologisme qui a repris cette
semaine à Emmanuel Macron maître
Bertrand Perrier va revenir sur
l'acquittement de Tariq Ramadan et les
conditions de son procès à Genève et
puis dans Bourbon Express ce soir une
proposition de loi sur le congé
menstruel titre révolution on verra ça
avec Marco pommier mais d'abord on va
parler un peu de vous Flora gabbali et
puis de ce syndrome de la fourmi qui
nous empêche d'agir des barrières
mentales qui nous enferment alors de
quoi s'agit-il et comment en sortir
l'invitation ce soir est signée
Stéphanie Despierre et on en discute
ensemble juste après
[Musique]
si on vous invite florag et balises
c'est parce que vous militez pour
changer de modèle et entrez vraiment
dans la transition écologique à 28 ans
vous incarnez cette nouvelle génération
par résigner mais engagé et bien décidé
à tout tenter pour sauver la planète
Flora gaybahi a pris un détour à la
communication de l'Elysée sous François
Hollande vous lancez une agence de
conseils qui aide les entreprises à
devenir plus verte chroniqueuse sur BFM
TV en 2022 vous publiez ma génération va
changer le monde vous avez créé un
podcast politique dans votre dernier
livre vous explorez ce que vous appelez
le syndrome de la fourmi
saviez-vous que lorsqu'on dessine un
cercle autour d'une fourmi elle est
incapable de s'en échapper elle croit
que le trait de crayon est un mur et
cette croyance l’empêche d'avancer
d'aller de l'autre côté c'est ça que
j'ai appelé le syndrome de la fourmi
cette étape paralysant qui nous empêche
de passer à l'action pour nous sauver du
désastre écologique vous êtes convaincus
que le changement passe par les
entreprises et pas par l'État les
politiques vous paraissent à côté de la
plaque vous prenez une transformation
radicale du système économique nous ne
sommes pas en guerre contre les énergies
fossiles nous sommes en guerre contre
notre système économique
avocate de la sobriété vous appelez
aussi à l'action individuelle c'est à
chacun de nous de se positionner de chez
pas à changer la mentalité de ses
collègues changer sa façon ses
comportements et ensemble on peut faire
bouger une civilisation pour obtenir des
politiques écologistes dignes de ce nom
il faut dites-vous construire des
rapports de force avec nos gouvernements
mais la révolution très peu pour vous
vous préférez la transition à condition
qu'elle démarre enfin alors dites nous
florag et Bali pour commencer cette
transition écologique quelle est la
première mesure à prendre
réponse la priorité des priorités pour
vous je dirais que c'est de
constitutionnaliser la planification
écologique et d'ailleurs ça revient à un
sujet budgétaire exactement sur le débat
qu'on vient d'avoir qui est comment on
finance qu'est-ce qu'on priorise et moi
j'aimerais que quand on vote le budget à
l'Assemblée au lieu de se demander
qu'est-ce qui rentre qu'est-ce qui sort
quoi comme on le fait actuellement on se
demande comment on protège les vivants
cette année et que le Parlement puisse
ouvrir un débat chaque année comme le
projet de loi de financement de la
France de la France
ou de la sécurité sociale
on réfléchisse à comment cette année on
va faire la planification écologique
alors c'est en cours ça puisque et ça
c'est la première fois la première
ministre a posé clairement une
planification avec des économies
d'énergie et surtout des réduction des
missions par secteur alors
malheureusement je suis pas la seule à
avoir cette cette envie là et cette
ambition là donc oui le gouvernement l'a
entendu et a créé un secrétariat général
à la planification éc ce qui est une
bonne chose mais je pense que tant que
on n'est pas capable de sortir du cercle
de la fourmi je pense qu'on va en parler
justement on pourra créer autant de
secrétariats généraux autant de lois
autant voilà là on va on va peut-être
aller sur l'ISS vert finalement on sera
toujours dans cette mécanique qui fait
qu'on fait un pas en avant trois pas en
arrière et que on n'arrive pas à changer
de civilisation alors c'est ça c'est la
question maintenant de la conscience
presque une conscience malheureuse on
sait mais on n'arrive pas à agir on sait
que la maison brûle on ne regarde plus
ailleurs on sort du déni mais en même
temps vous soulignez que savoir ne
suffit pas pour agir c'est l'effet note
in my in my backgard de quoi parle-t-on
précisément vous savez cette phrase la
maison brûle et on regarde ailleurs elle
date de 2002 et elle a été prononcée par
un président de droite Jacques Chirac
donc l'écologie n'est pas un sujet qui a
qui a émergé finalement seulement à
gauche il y a des grands discours que je
raconte dans le livre de Valéry Giscard
d'Estaing et geor qui ont allé à les
lire on dirait que c'est du Greta
Thunberg c'est ça impressionnant vous
vous combattez tous les clichés les
colos c'est pas forcément un gars de
gauche qui voilà ce c'est ce que
j'essaie de me la bougie parce que je
crois que le combat du moment c'est de
rendre l'écologie universelle et une
fois que ce sera le cas de discuter des
tenants et des aboutissants et
malheureusement aujourd'hui il y a on
demande pas suffisamment à nos
responsables politiques à nos dirigeants
de se positionner très fermement et je
crois que l'assemblée générale de Total
est un très bon exemple c'est que non on
ne peut pas être écologiste et soutenir
total c'est pas possible donc en fait il
faut maintenant donner des grilles de
lecture aux françaises et aux français
quand on soutient total on est on
soutient un crime contre la planète donc
il faut changer de lunettes en fait pour
vous et tout est histoire de récit j'ai
trouvé que c'était la dimension une des
dimensions les plus intéressantes du
livre il nous manque un narratif un
narratif heureux un moyen de se projeter
dans un futur désirable c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui les jeunes
sont parfois angoissées on parle de
l'écho anxiété comment comment l'écrire
ce récit là vous savez le narratif ça
paraît un peu superficiel quand on vient
d'avoir une discussion sur les taxes le
budget qu'on était avec des économistes
en costume-cravate on a l'impression que
moi je vous parle de grands récits de
grande histoire ça a un côté superficiel
mais en fait pas du tout c'est fondament
parce que le récit c'est en fait la
civilisation et d'ailleurs vous savez la
culture aujourd'hui on a un ministère de
la Culture on a l'impression que c'est
le ministère qui administre les arts
mais en fait ça devrait être beaucoup
plus large que ça et beaucoup plus
fondamental parce que la culture dans le
Larousse ça se définit comme les traits
communs à une nation les très commun à
une civilisation et moi ce que j'essaye
de raconter dans ce livre c'est comment
on crée une civilisation écologiste
parce que aujourd'hui on est dans un
modèle post révolution industrielle
comment parce que incompatible
qui conduirait le changement il faut
plus d'écologie dans les musées dans
notre histoire il faut écrire l'histoire
de France de notre pays d'un point de
vue de la nature du vivant de l'écologie
la première chose j'ai l'impression que
on dénonce vous savez les premiers
rapports sur les limites de la
croissance sont sortis en 1972 ça fait
plus de 50 ans donc j'ai l'impression
que la stratégie du bateau elle porte
ses fruits elle est très importante je
soutiens toutes les ONG et même celles
qui font de la désobéissance civile mais
je pense qu'elle est pas suffisante et
que aujourd'hui la stratégie du bâton
bon bah elle est plutôt mise en oeuvre
mais la stratégie de la carotte la
stratégie du désir de la désirabilité de
la transition elle est pas assez
déployée dans le récit collectif et je
pense qu'elle est très efficace la
sobriété peut être heureuse pour bien
sûr et puis surtout vu la crise de sens
qu'on a dans notre pays on a une crise
qui dépasse la crise climatique la crise
climatique est peut-être le plus gros
danger qui est face à nous aujourd'hui
mais quand on voit les gilets jaunes
dans la rue les gilets jaunes ils
demandaient quoi ils demandaient ce
qu'on les respecte ils demandaient à ce
qu'on les reconnaisse quand on voit que
que un adolescent sur cinq en France a
dépensé suicidaires excusez-moi moi ce
chiffre me choque énormément on devrait
s'intéresser à l'état mental la santé
mentale de nos adolescents donc tout ce
qu'il faut avoir
c'est ça c'est pas ce que je dis pas
manger de viande tu as pas éteint l'eau
ni la lumière tu tries pas les déchets
est-ce que c'est discours qui parfois
culpabilisent
et heureusement on est 70 millions dans
ce pays on est 8 milliards sur cette
planète c'est quand même normal qu'il y
ait des discours différents qui touchent
les gens de façon différente moi
personnellement j'ai été très touchée
par les discours à la à l'armiste mais
c'est peut-être une condition cognitive
propre à ma personnalité peut-être que
vous vous avez besoin d'autre chose vous
avez besoin qu'on vous montre que vous
avez un meilleur futur ailleurs et je
pense qu'on doit pas le limiter le
discours écologiste à à une certaine
intonation une certaine façon de de
créer un narratif et que au contraire on
doit pas que des collapsologues dans le
récit si je comprends bien un peu de
tout et après excusez-moi c'est un peu
plus complexe que ça encore une fois
parce que être collapsologue c'est
simplement voir que le modèle dans
lequel on est s'effondre donc oui le
modèle dans lequel on est s'effondre et
je pense qu'on doit dire la vérité aux
gens alors justement est-ce qu'il faut
complètement changer de modèle on sent
que vous préférez le mot de transition à
celui de révolution la radicalité j'ai
pas l'impression que ce soit forcément
votre votre truc
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on il faut changer
de système politique de régime vous je
voulais sortir de la Cinquième
République vous voulez sortir du système
de l'économie du marché libérale alors
moi je m'interroge et j'ai pas la
réponse est-ce que en 2023 les humains
ici en l'occurrence les Français et les
Français sont assez évolués pour être
capable de faire une révolution sans
violence
parce que quand on regarde à travers
l'histoire c'est quand tous ces effondré
qu'on a été capables de créer autre
chose on regarde 1945 le plan martial ça
a fait le modèle dans lequel on est il y
avait eu la guerre le pays était détruit
les tout était à reconstruire et donc on
a été capable de construire quelque
chose
je suis pas sûr de je suis pas sûr qu'on
soit capable de le faire cette fois-ci
sans violence je prends l'exemple de 45
mais on peut aussi prendre l'exemple de
1789 et de la révolution on est passé
quand même par un siècle de 100 pour
arriver à la démocratie il faut quand
même en avoir conscience et donc est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui on va réussir à éviter le
siècle de drame j'ai pas la réponse mais
comme je suis profondément optimiste je
me dis que c'est bien de poser la
question dernière toute petite question
vous avez participé à la formation de
des députés dans ces séminaires voilà de
familiarisation aux questions
climatiques aux enjeux sur le climat
vous les trouvez au point le députés sur
ces sujets là ça dépend lesquels moi
j'ai initié la question de
[Musique]
de obliger les responsables politiques à
avoir fait minimum 20h de formation aux
enjeux écologiques pourquoi parce que la
convention citoyenne pour le climat nous
a montré une chose qui est incroyable et
qui a pas été assez dite c'est que quand
on prend 150 français de tirés au sort
qui sont représentatives de toute la
diversité de français qu'on a dans le
pays et qu'on les forme et ben ils sont
tous radicaux ça devient tous des
activistes radicaux mais vraiment et
donc je suis convaincue que si on est
capable vraiment de former les députés
les parlementaires les sénateurs tous
nos élus alors on aura des politiques
écologiques qui seront beaucoup plus
concrètes maintenant il faut le dire on
a un parti politique qui s'appelle
Europe écologie des Verts et plus
globalement un groupe politique qui
s'appelle la nups ou il y a des
programmes politiques qui sont à la
hauteur et moi quand je veux
démocratiser l'écologie ça veut pas du
tout dire que je pense pas qu'il faut
avoir une vision politique de l'écologie
et considérer qu'aujourd'hui un député
RN ou un député LR à la même conviction
écologique qu'un député de la nups c'est
évidemment pas le cas l'écologie n'est
pas le monopole d'un parti politique
mais il y a des meilleures réponses par
partie sur le sujet que d'autres quand
on se forme je crois qu'on fait des
choix politiques assez évident j'espère
que j'ai réussi à sortir de ma prison de
mentale et donc du syndrome de la fourmi
Merci à VOUS Flora gaybahi c'est donc à
des rosés des cieux de l'Observatoire
voire et dépasser les barrières mentales
de l'inaction climatique vous restez
avec moi c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos
affranchis pour leur parti pris ils vont
vous faire réagir allez c'est à eux tout
de suite
Mariette d'arrêt grand bienvenue
installez-vous maître Bertrand perrier
c'est un plaisir de vous retrouver comme
chaque vendredi on va commencer
préparez-vous par le bourbon Express
bien sûr l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée nous est racontée ce soir
par Marco pommier bonsoir Marco bonsoir
Myriam et si demain les femmes pouvaient
s'absenter du travail en cas de règles
douloureuse sans perte de salaire chaque
mois beaucoup souffrent en silence près
d'une femme sur deux serait concernée et
pour certaines c'est un véritable
calvaire 3 députés écologistes ont donc
décidé de passer à l'offensive avec une
proposition de loi pour instaurer un
congé menstruel pour les femmes PPL
déposé aujourd'hui par Sébastien Petavy
marie-charlotte-garin et Sandrine
Rousseau
et en fait c'est s'il y a que un moment
on doit visibiliser ce que c'est que
d'avoir ses règles et les conséquences
que ça et si nous le faisons dans le
monde du travail alors il sera plus
facile pour chacune des personnes
monstruées en France de pouvoir réclamer
des droits au titre de cela et c'est
pour cela que cette proposition doit
être extrêmement importante alors à quoi
ça va ressembler la proposition c'est un
arrêt maladie de 13 jours maximum par an
un jour par cycle de réel de règles
alors il faudrait quand même présenter
un certificat médical délivré par des
généralistes des spécialistes
sage-femmes ou par la médecine du
travail l'arrêt maladie ne ferait pas
mention de la raison autre point
souligné la liberté de prendre ses jours
consécutivement ou séparément en
fonction des douleurs ressenties selon
les mois concrètement qu'est-ce que ça
changerait parce qu'aujourd'hui on peut
déjà se faire arrêter par son médecin
pour des règles douloureuses réponse
avec Sébastien Petavy
il y a plein de métiers et par exemple
si on prend une caissière aujourd'hui
belle elle ne peut pas utiliser le
télétravail elle a pas un très bon
salaire et si elle pose un arrêt avec la
carence et ben en fait elle a une double
peine et au niveau de la douleur et
financière et donc là le fait de faire
un arrêt permet justement de faire lever
le jour de carence et d'éviter une
pénalité financière
vous l'avez compris Myriam ce congé
menstruel en fait proposer par les
écologistes serait donc 100 jours de
carence un arrêt intégralement prise en
charge par l'assurance maladie alors
certaines entreprises n'ont pas
attendues les politiques pour mettre en
place un tel dispositif c'est le cas du
fabricant de mobilier Louis design
Carrefour va l'appliquer aussi dès cet
été en février c'est l'Espagne qui a
franchi le pas une première en Europe
oui mais voilà pour certaines
associations féministes c'est une fausse
bonne idée avec le congé menstruel il y
a certaines féministes qui craignent une
discrimination à l'embauche qu'est-ce
que vous leur répondez
mais je leur réponds que au contraire
c'est taré menstruel permet de lutter
contre la discrimination des femmes dans
le cadre du travail puisque aujourd'hui
tout le droit du travail mais toute la
santé au travail est conçue sur des
corps d'hommes et donc les femmes
aujourd'hui s'organisent c'est à dire
qu'elle prenne un jour de RTT elle
partent du travail en urgence un peu en
catimini elles prennent des jours de
congés elles prennent sur leur jours de
congé et en fait ça c'est inadmissible
c'est ça la discrimination aujourd'hui
et la proposition de loi va même encore
plus loin avec la volonté de
sensibiliser les entreprises et les
administrations publiques avec la mise
en place aussi de sanitaires adaptés
avec des protections menstruelles
addicts à disposition objectif faire
adopter cette proposition de loi dans le
cadre d'une semaine transpartisane à
l'Assemblée quoi qu'il en soit Myriam le
sujet des règles longtemps resté tabou
crée maintenant le débat et ça c'est
déjà une petite révolution absolument
c'est une bonne idée qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez sincèrement
je pense que c'est très bien de lever le
tabou qui a pu l'avoir pendant longtemps
sur les règles mais moi pour viser
l'égalité femme homme je préfère qu'on
augmente le congé paternité plutôt qu'on
crée un congé menstruel on a déjà
augmenté vous savez ouais mais pas assez
pas assez on n'est pas encore comme en
Norvège où il y a le même congé pour les
femmes et les hommes et je pense que
quand on commence à différencier trop
les travailleurs en fonction de leur de
leur genre ou de leur sexe c'est jamais
bon pour l'égalité bon bah on verra on
verra qu'à l'avenir à cette proposition
de loi si elle trouve une majorité dans
l'hémicycle ou pas Bertrand vous dit
revenir sur l'acquittement par la
justice suisse c'était avant-hier de
l'islamologue Tariq Ramadan oui Myriam
en effet mercredi après trois jours
d'audience le tribunal correctionnel de
Genève a acquitter Tariq Ramadan des
accusations portées à son encombre par
une femme qui est aujourd'hui âgée de 57
ans qu'on appellera donc Brigitte et qui
affirmatoire était violée par Tariq
Ramadan dans une chambre d'hôtel à
Genève en 2008 le parquet avait requis
trois ans de prison trois ans prison
pardon dont 18 mois ferme mais la
juridiction ce sont des juges ce ne sont
pas des jurés populaires en Suisse a
donc acquitté Tariq Ramadan acquittement
au bénéfice du doute oui au bénéfice du
doute le tribunal estime d'avoir pas
permis d'avoir une réelle certitude sur
la culpabilité il a reconnu que la
plaignante n'avait pas varié dans ces
déclarations mais il n'y avait pas de
preuve matérielles il n'y avait pas de
constellation médicale des vidéos
surveillance les témoignages apportés
par Brigitte n'ont pas été considérés
comme suffisamment fiable et en
définitive il a été relevé aussi que
après les faits Brigitte avait continué
à envoyer des messages affectueux Atari
Ramadan bon évidemment verdict salué par
Tariq Ramadan on le comprend il y a
aussi beaucoup de féministes pour qui
c'est une claque c'est une claque aussi
dans le déroulement de l'audience les
observateurs décrivent une audience
extrêmement déséquilibrée très dur à
l'égard de Brigitte qui a été
interrompue malmené on lui ordonnait de
se taire et à l'inverse très
complaisante à l'égard de Tariq Ramadan
qui pendant trois jours a pu dérouler
assez librement son discours selon
lequel il est victime d'un complot
d'affabulatrice qui veulent lui nuire et
nuire à l'islamologue qu'il est avec le
soutien un peu inattendu de Dieudonné
qui est venu témoigner pour lui alors
ce
est temporaire puisqu'il est il va y
avoir un appel les avocats l'ont fait
savoir de la partie civile ça pose aussi
une vraie question sur ce qu'il reste du
mouvement MiTo tout de même ce procès
oui une question assez simple c'est
est-ce que Mitou a franchi la frontière
suisse est-ce qu'il y aurait une sorte
d'exception culturelle helvétique en la
matière pour le dire très clairement
est-ce que Genève à 20 ans de retard et
on ne peut pas s'empêcher de bien sûr
dans une enceinte judiciaire le doute
profite personne n'est cru sur parole il
faut apporter des preuves il y a un
débat contradictoires mais les
conditions de recueil de la parole de
Brigitte la façon encore une fois elle a
été rudoyée par le tribunal un tribunal
ostensiblement fébrile hostile avec une
pression médiatique forte pose le
problème encore et toujours du recueil
de la parole des femmes et de l'écoute
qu'il aurait réservé on va probablement
avoir l'occasion de voir ce qui va se
passer en France puisque Tariq Ramadan
euh susceptible d'être renvoyé devant la
Cour d'assise en France pour des viols
qu'il aurait commis cette fois-ci sur
d'autres territoires merci carte blanche
Sting et Bertrand Perrier ça vous a
choqué vous ce verdict
je connais pas les les considérations
juridiques mais je crois que Ramadan
aussi des procès en courant en France
donc on verra quelle sera le jugement
mis tout à la place dans les prétois
merci Bertrand on termine avec un mot le
vôtre celui que vous avez choisi comme
chaque semaine Mariette vous vouliez
revenir sur ce mot ce néologisme en fait
des civilisations qui a employé Emmanuel
Macron dans le huis clos du Conseil des
ministres souhaitait mercredi dernier
qu'est-ce qu'il a voulu dire à votre
avis le président alors en fait je pense
qu'il a fait deux choses à la fois en
même temps c'est son habitude il a en
fait mêlé deux titres de livres premier
livre des civilisations c'est un livre
de Renault Camus auteur prolixe dans les
formulations donc il a créé ce
néologisme qui va bien avec sa théorie
durant remplacement mais il est pas dans
le dictionnaire souvent je l'ai pas
trouvé en revanche le second titre c'est
le processus de civilisation c'est un
grand classique des sciences humaines
écrit par Norbert Elias dans les années
39 et qui revient si vous voulez
justement sur ce que l'on peut appeler
civilisation alors Norbert Elias et
Chris livre dans la montée du nazisme
mais il en est victime il doit s'exiler
malheureusement mais il fait quelque
chose de tout à fait intéressant pour
notre histoire il va regarder ce qui se
passe dans les années 1380 14e siècle à
ambiance un peu Game of Thrones
dans les cours d'Allemagne et de France
cours c'est-à-dire que ça va donner la
courtoisie les chevaliers qui sont mal
dégrossis qui sont violents qui sont
guerriers etc acceptent quelque chose
probablement sur la demande des femmes
c'est une sorte de meeto avant l'heure
et il civilise leur force ils ils
commencent à pratiquer ce qu'il y a
s'appelle l'autocontrante c'est-à-dire
une intériorisation de la loi ils
acceptent de quelque chose qui est
fondamental et c'est ça qui va donner
finalement le vivre ensemble de notre
État moderne aujourd'hui ou la violence
est civilisée deux visions donc très
différentes de ce qu'est la civilisation
bah oui dans un cas on peut dire
civilisation c'est la culture bah en
France on aime la liberté la laïcité la
gas j'ai mis le luxe ça c'est on peut
dire la civilisation humaine c'est une
logique en quelque sorte ce que dit il y
a c'est ça qui pour nous est un héritage
fondamental c'est que la civilisation
s'est anthropologique c'est l'être
humain qui est en cause et le titre en
français du livre c'est la civilisation
des mœurs donc c'est le résultat si vous
voulez alors qu'il y a ça appuyé sur le
process process le processus de
civilisation il nous dit ça se fait pas
en un jour c'est long ça prend le
moyen-âge la Renaissance etc et dans
chacun de nous on voit bien avec les
enfants que nous éduquons ça prend
énormément de temps donc c'est jamais
gagné et la civilisation doit toujours
être mise sur le métier et nous devons
reprendre ce processus aujourd'hui vous
iriez oui je pense que c'est absolument
fondamental il faut vraiment qu'on
réfléchisse à ça collectivement c'est ça
qui nous arrive avec la montée des
violences ce qu'on appelle la moitié des
violences il faut être plus que
sociologue ou sociopolitique il faut
être anthropologue et il faut vraiment
considérer que ça passe il y a
s'explique en plus c'est très agréable à
lire c'est très intéressant qui dit ça
commence par ne pas se moucher dans ses
doigts la civilisation c'est comme ça
donc pour moi ce qui est à retenir de la
séquence de notre Président c'est que le
vrai la vraie répartition c'est pas
entre les gens civilisés et des gens qui
seraient décibilisés mais c'est entre
les gens civilisés quel que soit leur
origine quel que soit leur ethnie
qu'est-ce que quel que soit leur culture
d'appartenance et l'attachement à cette
culture voilà nous aimons être français
mais il y a les gens qui acceptent ce
processus de civilisation cette auto
contrainte pour vivre ensemble et les
autres soient inacceptent pas soit
malheureusement on peut dire sous
l'effet des substances ou autre
s'entendent ça de ce qu'il faut bien
appeler la civilisation humaine c'est
très juste et c'est très fin comme
d'habitude avec Mariette merci beaucoup
voilà j'espère que nous avons fait lien
en cette fin de semaine 1 le processus
de civilisation était j'espère à
l'oeuvre merci beaucoup Flora gibbali le
syndrome de la fourmi c'est-à-dire aux
éditions de l'Observatoire
Bertrand Mariette à la semaine prochaine
à très vite bien sûr Marco c'est le week
end profitez bien et donc à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]